Transcription: Samira Kwache
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Bonsoir.
Je ne sais pas par quoi commencer,
mais je vais séquencer.
Musique, culture,
radio, télévision,   guitare.
Ça fait MCRTG.
Je vous prie d’applaudir.
(Applaudissements)
Alors côté musique, je voudrais que…
J’ai naturellement baigné
dans une ambiance musicale
jusqu’à très bas âge.
J’ai connu le phono,
le vieux phono, c’est le phonogramme.
Pour ceux qui ne savent pas,
c’est l’ancêtre de tout
ce qu’on a aujourd’hui.
Des tourne-disques au magnétophone,
à l’électrophone jusqu’au CD.
Maintenant, on a la clé USB
et peut-être demain, autre chose.
Donc, le vieux phono,
le tourne-disque de 78 tours,
mais qui joue de la musique.
Imaginez-vous,
aux années de jouvence,
vous viviez dans cette ambiance.
Ensuite, c’est le magnétophone
puisque la maman était à la radio.
Je vous parle sous le contrôle
de Justin Morel junior.
Avec le magnétophone,
tout petit encore, à l’école primaire,
j’avais vu le Nagra
et je n’arrêtais pas de suivre ma mère
pendant les vacances, à la radio.
Et je vous dirais même
que c’est depuis
Radio Banane dans l’enceinte
de la cour de Sans Fil.
La première radio
a commencé là-bas, en fait,
avant de revenir au commissariat
qui n’est pas loin de Printania
qu’on a démoli.
J’y étais et j’y allais fréquemment.
C’était une maman très douce -
paix à son âme -
mais très dure.
« Tu feras ce que tu veux
mais tu étudieras. »
Une fois d’ailleurs -
Morel vous le dira un jour -
Justin Morel, dans ses années de stage
où il avait déjà crevé le plafond,
la maman l’a renvoyé de la radio une fois
parce que c’était les heures de cours.
« Si je te revois dans cette cour
alors que les autres sont en classe,
tu auras des problèmes. »
Bon, bref...
Il y avait encore un bénéfice.
Dans notre vie scolaire,
il fallait soit
faire le scoutisme, ce qu’on appelle
le mouvement pionnier,
une activité artistique ou culturelle
ou une activité sportive.
Donc tout naturellement,
moi, en 1967 déjà -
puisqu’on avait quitté la ville
pour la banlieue -
il y avait le 14 mai,
c’est-à-dire le lycée Château d’eau
avait créé un orchestre : le Star band
et nous, au lycée de Coleah,
ce qui est le lycée de Coleah aujourd’hui,
c’était le collège Courdeu.
En 1967, on crée le premier orchestre
et je m’essaie au chant
avec des amis comme Jeannot Barry
que beaucoup d’entre vous connaissent,
la famille Barry de Madina,
Bozo Mario et plein d’autres.
Ensuite, je saute les étapes.
Celle qui est la plus importante
et émouvante, c’est 1973,
la mort de Aboubacar Demba Camara.
Papa Kouyaté, paix à son âme,
décide de créer un orchestre
et fait appel à Justin Morel Junior
qui trouve tout de suite le nom,
puisque nous étions sept.
Il le fait baptiser « Sextet Camayenne ».
On était vers le quarantième jour.
En tout cas,
on n’avait pas atteint
le quarantième jour du décès
de Aboubacar Demba Camara
et c’était le 11 mai 1973
que nous avons eu l’occasion
de rentrer en studio.
Et Morel avait déjà écrit
le poème sur Demba.
Et là, nous nous retrouvons
et on enregistre.
C’était vraiment une musique profane,
avec des profanes, ça fait tilt.
Voilà que les problèmes commencent.
Nous aussi, on a su rebondir,
puisque ce terme-là, je veux
que les jeunes le comprennent.
En 1973, c’était l’âge d’or
de la musique guinéenne.
Ça a beaucoup de goût.
J'écoutais beaucoup de plaisir le jazz
avant notre entrée en scène ici.
Ils étaient indéplaçables.
Il était sur le toit de l’Afrique.
Alors voilà qu'un orchestre sort du lot.
« Un jam session », un terme de Justin.
Le jam session fait
six titres qui cartonnent.
Et ça fait beaucoup de bruit dans la cité
mais pour les jeunes,
c’était une innovation.
Et comme Justin avait ses termes
pour nous booster,
une musique par les jeunes
pour les jeunes.
Alors ça a créé le choc,
comme l’a dit mon frère,
au niveau des Aînés.
Ça n’a pas été facile.
Bon, au fil du temps,
amoureux de la chose,
on se dit bon d’accord, puisque...
En fait, on voulait ressembler,
faire comme eux,
dire que c’était possible.
On a insisté
et voilà qu’on avait été programmé
pour une soirée officielle
au PRL Manguier Garderie.
Pour ceux qui ne savent pas
le PRL - Pouvoir révolutionnaire local -
Aujourd’hui, c’est un quartier...
parce que je parle à plus jeune.
Manguier Garderie,
c’est derrière l’imprimerie.
D’ailleurs, Tabassi Ebaro qui est là,
va faire la première affiche
et la première photo.
Son salon va nous permettre même
de répéter
mais, cette soirée... problèmes.
Parce que simplement,
le nom de l’orchestre choque
« Les autres s’appellent Jazz, Band,
Sextet vient d’où ?»
Mais heureusement pour nous,
le Quintet Makeba existait déjà.
Alors, on a trouvé des astuces :
des jeunes intelligents,
on a décidé de prendre madame
Delphine Béavogui comme marraine -
l’épouse du Premier ministre
de l’époque -
et a intégré son fils
au sein de l’orchestre.
Ça aussi, ça a pris.
On est venu lui raconter
qu’on veut nous mettre en prison,
on veut faire ceci et cela,
mais ça ne marche pas.
Elle dit tout de suite :
« Vous serez dans le bureau
du responsable suprême de la révolution.
Vous vous expliquez là-bas,
il va vous prendre. »
Et là, on va dans deux
véhicules présidentiels
On était tout jeunes.
Imaginez-vous, le président Ahmed
Sékou Touré allume sa cigarette -
c’est des petits souvenirs
que je vous raconte.
Voilà que Papa Kuate aussi,
allume sa cigarette.
Justin à côté,
il a failli lui arracher le pied.
« Le président fume, tu fumes ? »
(Rires)
Et il nous observe.
C'est vraiment un spectacle.
Voilà, laisse ça, ça vient.
Alors, Papa se sert de la paume de sa main
devant le président pour éteindre le feu.
Alors, les choses ont marché.
Écoutez le problème... Je simplifie.
C’est votre simple volonté
de vous mettre ensemble.
Je le dis parce que politiquement,
vous ne pouvez pas exister.
Vous ne connaissez pas,
vous lirez les tomes là-bas.
La structure du parti était telle
que si tu résidais en banlieue,
c’est-à-dire à Conakry II,
tu devais appartenir
à une structure sportive,
artistique et autres de Conakry II.
Et chez nous, ça faisait
Conakry I et Conakry II.
Donc, ils nous ont battus là :
« Vous ne pouvez pas...
Vous n’êtes pas dans la même école.
- Nous savons.
Président, tout ça, c’est bien.
Mais puisque nous, on a démarré.
C’est votre slogan qui est dit :
′ La jeunesse a toujours raison. ′
Donnez-nous raison, on s’en va. »
Notre première soirée aussi,
c’est le camp Boiro qui nous attend.
« Philip B. vous êtes tenace ! »
D’accord.
Alors, de ce pas,
je vous invite à aller
dans mes voitures au Camp Boiro.
Siaka sera votre parrain. »
Alors là, ça se complique.
« - Est-ce-qu’on pourra ?
- Non, allez-y. »
Bon, bref,
quand on aime une chose
et qu’on va jusqu’au bout,
on peut, si vous voulez,
bousculer l’ordre établi.
Donc, on a bousculé l’ordre établi.
Cette soirée a été bien réussie.
Effectivement, le parrain était là
et ceux qui devaient l’encercler
le prennent.
Ce sont eux qui devaient
devait rentrer ce jour, au Camp Boiro.
Alors depuis lors,
ça a éclaté et ça a continué.
Je ne vous dis pas ce que ça a engendré
comme succès.
Je me rappelle encore,
on disait que c’était la seconde
révolution de la musique guinéenne.
Bon, je ne rentre pas
dans plus de détails.
Carmen Soufra, en tout cas,
vous continuez à l’écouter.
C’est une œuvre collégiale parce que,
simplement, c’était une constellation
de ce que vous appelez
aujourd’hui : The Star
On était pas des stars mais chacun de nous
se battait pour être star,
mais dans un esprit collectif.
C’est pourquoi je suis heureux de voir
Garmon Touré, devant moi, aujourd’hui.
Les autres n’ont pas pu venir
parce qu’il y en a treize
qui sont de l’autre côté.
Musique,
avec bien sûr la guitare.
Et vous savez,
comme le disait Charles Trenet,
quand on joue de la guitare,
c’est comme on écrit un journal intime.
Le journal intime, tu l’auras bientôt.
Alors radio...
Aux jeunes, vous pouvez avoir des diplômes
dans des secteurs bien déterminés.
Mais le destin vaut les autres choses.
Beaucoup d’entre vous, même mes amis,
peu savent que j’ai fait
géologie et mines.
J’y ai exercé de 1977 à 1980 - 3 ans -
Bon, je n’aime pas pourquoi
je n’ai pas continué.
Le Palais des Nations, nous y avons été
pour faire la prospection et les sondages.
Alors, dès que, la boue a jailli,
j’ai dit à mes amis :
« C’est ce qu’on a appris ?
Moi, je m’en vais ! »
Bon, écoutez, c'était une anecdote.
En 1980, je dis à la maman
que je vais la rejoindre à la radio.
Elle me dit
« Je te l’avais dit au départ.
Depuis bébé, tu viens à la radio.
Pourquoi tu es parti ailleurs ? »
Ça s’est passé dans les règles de l’art
et depuis 1980,
je suis à la radio.
Et là aussi,
je suis avec des ainés, des amis
et des copains de ma mère
comme Emmanuel Kathy et Milton Papa
qui étaient déjà des icônes et des idoles
que moi, je voulais imiter.
J'y arrive.
J'ai pas eu le courage de commencer
par l'animation ou le journalisme.
Je ne savais pas.
Justin et les autres avaient dit
que j’avais des talents cachés.
Donc, j’ai dit non,
je commence par la technique
et surtout par la prise de son
puisque je suis musicien.
Généralement, ceux qui voyagent
sont les musiciens,
qui sont de très bons ingénieurs du son.
Donc, je suis technicien,
en fait, par défaut.
Une fois dans le studio,
la direction décide.
Maintenant, je vais dans le bureau
d’Emmanuel Kathy.
Je crois que Justin et les autres
avaient fait un complot.
J’entends les autres dire :
« Ce n’est pas la place de Jeannot,
il ne peut pas nous être utile là-bas.
Jeannot est bien au micro
parce qu’on le voit animer
avec son orchestre.
C’est lui le porte-parole. »
Alors, je viens là.
Ma première émission,
je ne l’oublierai jamais.
Et je citerai toujours Justin Morel Junior
parce que c’était musique comparée,
la toute première.
Il me donne toute la documentation
de la célèbre chanson
Guajira Guantanamera.
Toute la documentation
pendant presque trois mois.
J’étais même obligé d’arrêter
parce qu’il y a 1000 et une version,
avec des textes bien faits.
Une chanson de José Martí
Je me rappelle, c’est José Martí
et mieux, c’est aussi Joselito Fernandez,
qui en 1939, chanta pour la première fois
cette belle chanson.
Alors tout s’est passé ainsi
parce que simplement,
j’avais beaucoup d’amour
pour ce que je faisais.
Et je sais que je m’étais choisi...
Exerçant dans la radio depuis,
alors les émissions se sont multipliées
les stages tombent.
Le Canada m’a aussi beaucoup aidé,
par trois fois.
la Belgique, RFI, Radio France,
Bordeaux, Gironde...
...des tournées avec les ensembles
artistiques, dont les Ballets africains
Plusieurs tournées en Europe,
en Amérique, en Chine, partout.
Et plusieurs rencontres
avec des grands journalistes
dont on ne savait
pas qu’ils nous écoutaient.
Voyez-vous,
ça m’a encore donné
beaucoup plus de tonus.
Côté radio, passé sur le Mondial,
vous en avez parlé.
On a commencé
par le Hit-Parade international
parce que jusqu’à cette époque,
on n’avait pas de Hit-Parade en Guinée.
Il n’y avait pas de hit parade
et c’était difficile.
Et moi, je ne voulais pas faire le contenu
car le contenant n’était pas là.
Donc j’ai réussi à convaincre
les deux directions.
Moi, je préfère qu’on dise Sono Mondiale
parce qu’en fait, on se servait
des bandes d’émissions musicales
de la Deutsche Welle,
de La Voix de l’Amérique et de la RFI.
On pique dedans.
C’était à l’époque
de l’analogique et des magnétos.
On pique deux ou trois morceaux,
puis, on retourne la bande
parce qu’elle doit retourner à la base.
On a fait tellement d’acrobaties
mais ça nous a réussi, paraît-il.
Et voilà, ces émissions
sont devenues célèbres
grâce à l’amour
pour ce qu’on faisait
et ce qu’on s’était choisi.
Maintenant, l’administration, c’est-à-dire
la gestion et la culture
et avec Justin,
nos destins se croisent à nouveau.
Il est ministre de l’information
et de la culture.
Et voilà, il va y avoir des
jeux de muets, des zones
Ils m’ont nominé
directeur national de la culture.
Et c’est le poste que j’ai assumé
avec ce que je pouvais faire
pendant 12 ans et sept mois.
Mais avant, j’avais été
chef de la section culturelle de la radio
et chef du service culturel
pendant, je crois, 17 ans ou moins.
Vous pouvez faire le calcul.
Voilà les postes de responsabilité,
sans compter ce que je faisais
à la radio et deux fois à la télévision
jusqu’à ce soir.
Demain, on est dimanche
et aujourd’hui c’est samedi.
Si vous êtes à l’écoute à 19h05,
« Les merveilles du passé » continu
et ce, depuis 1987.
Certes, elle n’est pas
la plus ancienne émission
mais elle est encore là.
Si je n’aimais pas mon travail,
j’aurais pu arrêter
mais la casquette de directeur
ne m’a pas gêné.
Voilà ce que j’ai pu apporter
par le simple fait
que j’aimais ce que je faisais.
Donc,
(Applaudissements)
à ce niveau,
je ne vais pas vous retenir longtemps.
Je vais vous dire merci.